I don't know if you've heard there's a
site that can really help you get
educated that all of you should be
referencing to get all the information
for modern marketing by the hour you can
write it down you ready g o o g l e
google.com how do I produce content for
LinkedIn enter free how do I do
influencer marketing for my caviar
business enter free how do I do a
podcast how do I make a podcast how do I
upload my podcast to itun stud enter
free anything you can think of the
amount of information for free is
staggering and then you could decide if
you're good reader or if you're more
like me and we'll watch a video of
course some of it isn't great which is
why I want you to spend 10 hours so you
can cross reference and not just the
first article this is not a game of you
don't know how to do it this is a game
of you chose not to do it